the jurgen experience
do you um do you anticipate writing
with new characters are you going to
keep jack reese like how how are you
going to do this yeah so james reese
yeah for this why is jack jack is john
sometimes sometimes right so john f
kennedy jack
that sort of thing yep no it's easy to
do and then you have jack reacher
character you have jack ryan
you know he's really john ryan from the
clancy stuff so
yeah james reese the main character
former navy seal sniper background
similar to mine but right now it's so
hard to get an audience to connect with
your character
and i didn't even think about that as i
started but since that's happened since
he is resonating with people and the
stories are resonating with people
that i think i'm going to continue on
with the same character the same
storyline
um building on it building along his
journey because we're all on this
journey and people can
relate to that as well to transitions
and move different struggles and all
that so
i'm going to continue with this
character for as long as people want to
continue to read about them
so did you feel like you just hit gold
so you're you're in a
nice [ __ ] vein of gold in this map
you might as well just keep running i
think so i mean you could uh i heard a
story of
my um from my editor and she has another
another author that
uh that had kind of the same thing like
people his character was resonating and
he said i think i'm gonna do something
different
and she's like what no you're not no you
know how rare this is
so right like jk rawlings she had this
amazing success with harry potter and
then she wrote another book
and you know i mean i'm sure it's
probably pretty successful just because
she's
jk rawlings and everybody loves her but
i haven't heard [ __ ] about it no
sometimes it's hard to move over what's
the new book about
magic no maybe not i don't know i feel
like i knew something i couldn't tell
you what it is i have no idea i'm sure
it sold a million copies
because everything she does yeah she
could you know so we all know harry
potter like that is part of the culture
now
yeah it is that is a part of the culture
but uh but yeah i'm continuing on
continuing on with this for a while but
i'll do other projects
as well like i learned a ton working on
these scripts and i didn't know anything
about screenwriting going into it and
the screenwriter david agilio awesome
guy out there in la he really just kind
of mentored me along and we worked on
these things
together and i got to advise on each of
them so i got to see how that process
went
got to see what it looks like when you
bring a writer's room in that i knew you
have experience with and now you have 15
people
and they're all giving their different
ideas uh to how to adapt your work so
it's really interesting
not physically so they sent me the uh
yeah so covet hit pretty
pretty soon into it uh so they were all
virtual too so they're all doing that uh
that virtual the room
was virtual so you did a virtual meeting
though so you were at least uh
digitally in presence so was it weird
having people
talk about your creation and sort of
move it around
and do they keep all the main characters
like katie
and yeah wife and his daughter and all
that stuff is
yeah they so chris wanted to keep so
chris optioned it right out of the gate
chris pratt
so january of 2018 before it even hits
shells chris pratt options it because
my dear friend jared shaw gives him a
copy and says this is your next project
which is just by the way
who's better than chris pratt i can't
think of anybody he's my favorite chris
he's great he's he's just such a great
guy he is
and for him like it's he's perfect for
that role
so perfect he's a you know he's done you
know he had a small role in zero dark 30
where he plays a navy seal
and very small apart but uh you know his
other stuff hasn't been as violent
hasn't been as visceral hasn't been as
primal and so people are going to be
surprised
how graphic is this going to be pretty
graphic
well the books are so graphic here we
are
there we are right there yep i think
that was uh antoine wasn't supposed to
post that so
we're so so glad that he did that you
[ __ ] up on chris's page actually
yeah chris did it too chris reposted it
which is great uh but so antoine and
antoine fuqua right there
man he is such an amazing guy um so he
did training day
did tears of the sun magnificent seven
shooter equalizer
um and it's one of those guys like when
you meet him and you're in this in his
presence
like something's different you know you
have this like you meet a lot of people
that come through here
and uh maybe a couple of them have had
that sort of presence
incredible it's such a nice guy so
having chris and antoine at the top of
this thing
so many people came up to me on set and
just told me hey this feels different
than other movies
we've worked on like everybody from you
know craft services to whatever else
technical advisors you know all coming
in saying this is different and plus we
had like 12 seals on set guys that i
knew
in the teams that are there playing
seals or acting in the in it or doing
stunt coordination or technical advising
or whatever it is
um so we were all on so it was like a
reunion so we had a blast
it was a huge reunion for a week on set
and we had a we had a blast but
yeah it could not be you and you trust a
lot of this is trust so when you hand
something over to somebody to take your
work
and change it into something and adapt
it to film or it can be anything
but uh there's a lot of trust involved
because you're especially me when uh if
you're not jk rowling or you're not uh
you know stephen king and you're not
maintaining creative control uh
you hand that to somebody else and you
cross your fingers and there's no better
there's no two better people to be in
charge of this than chris pratt and juan
fuqua
they're incredible people catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience